Narrator: Europe is leading
one of the most important space
travel efforts of this century.
It's a mission called RemoveDEBRIS,
and if all goes according to plan,
it could save the future of space travel
as we know it.
The objective of
RemoveDEBRIS is just that.
Demonstrate how we could remove
space debris that's cluttering up
Earth's orbit,
including pieces of used up rockets
and retired satellites.
Even though you can't
see it from the ground,
there are more than half a million
chunks of space trash flying around
our planet,
and most of it is concentrated
in low earth orbit,
where it whips around at 28,000 kilometers
an hour.
Fast enough to fly from LA to London,
in just 19 minutes,
but here's the trouble with that.
Low earth orbit is our
front door to the universe.
To get anywhere in space,
whether it's the
International Space Station,
Mars, or beyond,
we have to cross that threshold first,
but if you have a bunch of garbage
blocking your path,
it's gonna be difficult.
Even worse,
experts, like astrophysicist
Donald Kessler,
fear that just one collision
between two large objects,
could seal up that opening forever,
because it would set off
a chain reaction.
One collision after another,
after another,
which could produce
thousands of additional
pieces of debris.
This domino effect is called the
"Kessler Syndrome,"
after Donald Kessler himself,
and it predicts that low earth orbit
could become littered with space trash,
making it too dangerous for spacecraft
to fly through,
or also reduce their life spans
because of collisions.
That's where Europe's
RemoveDEBRIS mission comes in.
In 2018,
it successfully tested the first
of four stages of its trash
clean up technology,
and it looked like this.
This is not an illustration.
This is actually happening in space.
That's a net about the size of
a large dining room tablecloth,
ensnaring a small spacecraft
that the mission team planted
for the experiment.
Now, this was just the first
of what will, hopefully,
be many more tests,
because in the future,
we're gonna need a bigger net.
Guglielmo S. Aglietti:
At the end of the day,
the final goal is to be able to
capture very large targets,
so, possibly what one of the targets
that has been mentioned,
as a potential one,
is an old satellite,
Envisat,
and it is maybe the size of a bus.
Narrator: Scientists
have been proposing ways
to clean up space junk
since the early 90s.
They've thought of everything,
from lasers,
to robotic claws.
But this is the first time any concept
has actually been tested in space.
The team hopes to test its other
three technologies, as well,
which involve a harpoon,
for spearing the trash,
a navigation system for
analyzing the trash's
size, distance,
and rotation,
and a sail for slowing the trash down,
so it can reenter,
and burn up in Earth's atmosphere.
But all this technology isn't the reason
this mission has come closer than any
before it.
Aglietti: Everybody agrees,
that to remove some of
this debris,
is the right thing to do,
but, clearly, the issue is going to be,
you know, the cost.
Narrator: The RemoveDEBRIS project has
cost 15 million euro,
or, about 17 million US dollars.
Aglietti: The current
mission was sponsored
by the European community,
and, again, we had, you know,
ten partners, working on this project,
and, overall, the cost of this project
was about, you know,
€15 [million].
When you are going to do
this kind of mission,
for real,
the cost will be higher,
and, so, I think the various stakeholders
around the world,
have to get together,
and decide how such mission could
be funded.
We are talking about not just,
you know, the UK,
or, maybe, NASA, but also,
China, you know, Russia, and so on.
The problem is, again,
who is going to pay for it?
Narrator: So, Europe has taken the lead.
Rest of the world,
it's your turn now.